so i auditioned for the bachelorette a  couple months back and much to my shock  surprise and ah i was rejected  so i decided to make my own version of  the bachelorette on tinder so the  bachelorette tinder edition  and it says please fill out this form to  apply for the bachelorette tinder  edition the rules are as follows  contestants will be sent a zoom link for  the show  on night one each contestant will  introduce themselves and then a virtual  cocktail party will happen  a first impression rose will be given  out and the top contestant of the night  will receive a one-on-one zoom date with  pearl  so then they have to answer their name  their age their job school a fun fact  stepping out of the limo what would you  say the favorite response will get a  first impression rose  are you free this saturday or this  sunday at seven do you have zoom and  what is your phone number and snap so  i've never made a tic tac before but  like if you want to see what happened  next